make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back again with another installment
of how to kill Super Heroes and today
we're focusing on everyone's favorite
horse version of Thor beta ray bill but
before we decide how to put him out to
pasture or send him off to the glue
factory we'll go over the origin and
powers of beta ray bill to see just why
killing him if such a difficult task so
beta ray bill was created by Walt
Simonson and first appeared in the
Mighty Thor number 337 in 1983 and when
discussing the creation of beta ray bill
Simonson said that his objective was to
play on the inscription on Thor's hammer
which states that whosoever was worthy
will possess the power of Thor up to
that point no one but Thor had ever been
able to lift the hammer but the
inscription indicates that it is
theoretically possible something that a
lot of Marvel fans seem to forget during
the events of secret Empire when evil
Captain America managed to pick it out
everybody seemed to remember the
inscription is saying whosoever lifts
this hammer holds his hammer if he be a
good guy shall possess the power of Thor
but it doesn't say anything about being
a good guy it says everything about
being worthy but Mueller is a weapon
designed for killing and so Simonson
wanted a noble warrior to be the one to
lift it and so of course he created beta
ray bill to fit that mold now as for his
comic book origin beta ray bill belongs
to a race of aliens known as the
korbinites who were almost completely
wiped out when their galaxy was
destroyed by Sirte but bill was chosen
to be the guardian of the few korbinites
that remained and underwent a process
that turned him into a cyborg while also
giving him the characteristics of an
equine like species needed to his home
planet of corbin now bill is placed in
stasis aboard the sentient ship scuttle
but until he's awakened by an alert that
the ship is in danger which happened to
be thor who was sent by shield to
investigate the fleet and who caused the
ship to detect the same magical energy
that had destroyed corbin due to both
being its guardian in nature and so bill
is then summoned to Asgard by Odin when
he demonstrates his ability to lift
Thor's hammer and Odin does the only
logical thing he organizes a battle to
the death between his son and this horse
looking alien that he just met to
determine who should rightfully wield
the owner makes perfect sense
hashtag comic book logic now the battle
takes place in a fiery region of Asgard
known as scars hunt and results in both
Thor named beta ray bill incapacitating
one another but because bill's more
acclimated to extremely hot climates he
recovers first and is declared the
winner that was kind of like
Last Man Standing match right and both
guys are unconscious and one guy gets up
right before the 10-count wrestling
reference now though bill could have
left Thor to die he decides to save him
which impresses Odin but rather than
give me honor to bill Odin just makes
him a hammer that's equal in power and
made of the same metal as Mjolnir and
then calls its storm breaker
now in addition to being a powerful
weapon Stormbreaker also allows bill to
return to his original korbinite form
whenever he chooses and so bill then
agrees to help the Asgardians defeat
Surtur and his forces and he's been a
recurring character in the Thor books
and cosmic stories ever since now
because bill's consciousness has been
placed inside of a cyborg he has
incredible strength speed and durability
he's a skilled hand-to-hand fighter and
this is made even more formidable by
storm breaker which is one of the most
powerful weapons in the entirety of the
Marvel Universe now bill is also able to
absorb manipulate and project vast
quantities of energy and has shown
himself to be capable of wielding enough
energy to destroy an asteroid and using
Stormbreaker
he was able to absorb an energy attack
by the Silver Surfer so to get a sense
of how strong bill is using Stormbreaker
he's able to crack the armor of Galactus
with it after he had already used it to
cut through one of Galactus energy
blasts and at the fact that he was able
to stalemate Thor in battle didn't
already convince you of how powerful
beta ray bill is is worth mentioning
that their first encounter
resulted in the destruction of the
surrounding countryside now as if that
weren't enough bill is capable of taking
an insane amount of damage which is
what's going to make killing him an
especially difficult prospect he
survived
exploding planets a blast from Galactus
and being at the center of a star he can
use Stormbreaker to create portals to
anywhere in the universe manipulate
weather heal himself and others and
create force fields capable of
withstanding a blast from nova and the
fire from super scroll which is meant to
approximate the fire produced by the
Human Torch and so with all that in mind
what's the best way to go about turning
horse Thor into glue I think what we're
going to have to do first is separating
from Stormbreaker Stormbreaker
is an incredibly powerful weapon and
most of those attributes are derived
from his use of this weapon
and since Stormbreaker is basically a
copy of Mjolnir that means that only
those who are worthy to lift it can
actually wield it and so I think the
best way to separate doll from
Stormbreaker
is to make him believe that he's no
longer worthy to wield it similar
we saw a habit of Thor when Nick Fury
whispered into his ear there Gore was
right which resulted in Thor being
unable to lift me on here for quite a
while something some Thor fans still
can't get past but like I said when that
story first launched Thor would get the
hammer back and guess what he did and I
think that ultimately this is going to
require either an extremely powerful
telepath to plant the thought into beta
ray bill's brain or someone who can bend
reality to trick him into thinking that
he did something that would make him
unworthy but Stormbreaker is not the
only outside force that we need to worry
about depriving Bill we also need to
worry about scuttlebutt as the sentient
ship is able to heal bill of any of the
damage he suffers so if we're going to
kill him we need to take away any
opportunity that he has to heal so we
might as well blow up scuttlebutt before
we even engage bill in doubt but even
with that done and storm breaker off the
table killing bill is still a tall order
as he's still an accomplished fighter
and a being of incredible strength and I
think our best bet here is to try and
use Bill strengths his cybernetic
anatomy against him if we're able to use
some sort of electromagnetic pulse or
some other means of electrical
manipulation to mess with the circuitry
that makes up his cyborg physiology that
could give us the opportunities that we
need to take him down it won't be an
easy task as we're dealing with alien
technology here but there are so many
advanced Minds in the Marvel Universe
that we can figure out some comic book
science that'll allow us to infiltrate
this technology and take bill down for
good failing that it would probably just
take an enormous amount of energy to get
the job done keeping in mind that Thor
was unable to defeat bill but more
powerful cosmic entities like the
lactose could probably get the job done
especially we first succeed in
convincing bill that he's unworthy to
wield Stormbreaker so yeah
that's how I see it we finally managed
to find a way to kill bill and it didn't
take two movies so if you guys have a
better idea let me know down in the
comments section if you guys have any
other characters that you would like to
see killed in future videos uh let me
know if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you hit the sub button
to become a part of the Rob Ford if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you